if your business is on life support
today I'm gonna share with you the three
ways to save your business from failing
hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently got a question for one of my
YouTube subscribers love you guys
anyhoo wrote in to say are you in a
small photography studio and it seems
that conventional advertising is not
working and I need to generate some
revenue fairly quickly to support my
lease I applied for loans but because I
have returned in a heart condition no
one is willing to give me the money out
of risk I might die what can I do to
save my shop this is a great question
Amy thank you so much for writing in I
feel the stress and the angst and the
despair and the genuine desire to want
to make this business work and so here
are the three bits of device that I
would have to help you save your company
number one is live within your means
this is a little bit of tough love but
if you can't afford the lease for your
business then maybe you shouldn't have a
shop one of the biggest mistakes that
most entrepreneurs make is they start
spending money before they're making
money
anybody can spend money the trick is to
find customers start making money and
start building a business around them
and then you expand when you can afford
to expand now losing a shop doesn't mean
you have to close your business you can
do what you probably should have done in
the start is out of your home start
small build a customer base get revenue
coming in make sure you can pay your
bills and then expand and the last thing
you want to do is take out a loan
because now if the business doesn't work
they're gonna come after your house so
cut back on your expenses and that may
mean losing the shop and go out and get
customers so that you have a profitable
business number two is pick a niche and
form alliances listen there are tons of
photographers there are tons and tons
and tons of photographers what makes you
different you've got to pick a niche
that you excel at that you love dealing
with these kinds of people and then
express it in every communication that
you put out there so if you're writing a
question to me I love this here you say
hey I'm a photographer and I specialize
in taking pictures of athletes that
gives me a lot more context to help you
because if you're just a general
photographer there's so much competition
and it's really hard to stand out so you
want to pick your niche
then form alliances with people who can
help you sell into that niche so an
example is a buddy of mine named Richard
who was a celebrity photographer he has
a website called you gotta love and he
specializes in photography for
celebrities he's worked with acts like
Lady gaga
and high-profile rappers and musicians
and then he forms alliances with people
who are already selling to those
musicians and celebrities who work with
music agents and he'll work with music
labels and who work with people who
represent these stars already they have
a big client pool that they can
potentially introduce him to and because
he is the expert in that field he's
likely to get the business so pick a
niche that you were really good at that
you really want to target these kinds of
customers and then go form alliances
with people who have complementary
products and services that can introduce
you to their clients and number three is
provide amazing service your service
based business and the number one way
the service based businesses grow is
through referrals you should be able to
build a three hundred thousand dollar
business just on your own and just
through referrals and that counts by
providing amazing service after somebody
does a photo shoot with you what extra
value can you bring them so that they
can't wait to go and tell their friends
about you as an example the guy who shot
my wedding was named Brian and he's got
a company called tarsi pix he went way
over and above what was expected of him
he came the day before the wedding and
took shots of the setup he came with us
throughout the whole day of the wedding
he took pictures not just of us but of
every single guest that came out to the
wedding and then he made baseball cards
for us personalized to each individual
who came to the wedding he went way way
way way way above what I expected from a
wedding photographer and as a result now
every time I know someone is getting
married I say you kind of go work with
Brian I even made a video thanking him
for his amazing work doing your job and
providing good pictures is not enough
you have to over-deliver like crazy so
they can't wait to go out and tell their
friends about you so live within your
means pick a niche and form alliances
and provide amazing service and belief
for those who are watching I love to
know
how you live within your means how you
got your business from the bootstraps up
and how you overcame those early
obstacles leave it in the comments below
share your story I'd love to hear and it
can also help inspire other people who
are going through that same problem and
if you like this video you want to see
more don't forget to subscribe to the
newsletter and the channel thank you for
watching I'll see you soon